launch looks like Galloway's keep him
busy kid it's me over here Jimmy Cisco
I'm in disguise yeah I can see that
beautiful isn't it that house is built
on lies and it's time for a confession
man open wounds three that that is a
modern classic classic I'm sorry kid I
didn't I didn't know you were such a fan
yeah yet here was yeah yeah I guess I
[ __ ] up tonight seems to be a running
theme in that there's always time for a
fresh start like right here right here
and right now you know kid maybe not
right here and right now I don't know if
I can go back in there I guess all good
just tell me what to look for I got you
right ah right okay so uh there's a lift
that will take you down into the
basement in the basement there's a room
inside the plume there are ancient
Sumerian tablets said to have been
written by the visitor himself no hey
man I'm serious and they they are deadly
serious okay man now I believe you
that's perfect okay look if you need
anything else you let me know
okay gang i'm about to sneak inside new
Dawn's temple and Jimmy's agreed to
deliver a special message for our video
we're all set up once you read the
treasure watch out for snakes there are
always sneaks it's not that kind of
Temple ring that does not resist aches
I'll be careful
duck died on my walk Oh
he gave us a slip come on let's regroup
Oh over there
give it up you're all
blue
don't see anyone moving on Taylor
huh that's got to be Jimmy's elevator
I've unlocked the secret lift I can't
believe you actually said that what it's
true
welcome to the fifth level of the new
dawn and congratulations on your
spiritual descendants thank you I worked
hard for it
we're looking at new Dawn's prized
possessions the foundation of their
entire religion rows of ancient Sumerian
tablets there's a lot of crazy [ __ ] in
here but this no this this is something
special why are they in a museum I mean
what gives the church the right to keep
these hidden away from us let's find out
oh it says do not touch but i really
want to touch I'm just a little come on
so much rich history I mean I am so glad
to be a part of although no no no no no
no they're [ __ ] fake this is all
[ __ ] people commit to new dawn pay
millions of dollars before they get to
see these and they're fake as fake as
everything else the church promises mmm
yeah now I feel better let's go home
come in behold good sec decided to dig
into the church of the new Don and found
crime in Russia as they purchase large
amounts of personal data to better
target guarantees they may already have
a file on mark we I personally every
cool collected to our usual just not
this repair from there you will come to
the same conclusion new dawn is a
criminal organization designed to
intimidate his phone numbers into
destroying their own lives and handing
over their savings to it don't take our
word for it we have a celebrity guest
yes hello I'm Judy Seska you probably
remember me from a bunch of good movies
I made before I was brainwashed by new
delighted forced to toe the company line
we're friends of mine question the
trenches home practices then disappear
when I questioned that I was taken
against my will and walked away no the
police are already investigating my
claims and what is the church all about
what's behind door number five I'll up
my friends and debts that demonstrate
does that just given you the truth
come on guys you're [ __ ] welcome